Baltimore's Police Commissioner says
there is no doubt that drugs were
recovered in two cases involving alleged
police misconduct two separate body
camera videos show Baltimore officers
purportedly faking evidence one captures
officers recovering drugs from a car in
November the other from a back yard in
January defense attorneys in both cases
say the footage shows officers planting
drugs jeff Piquet's is in Baltimore with
the investigation and the fallout for
police Jeff good morning good morning
already prosecutors in this city have
had to drop dozens of criminal cases
since these body camera videos of
surfaced and the reality is this may not
be the end of it for a Baltimore police
department that is now once again
defending itself against allegations of
misconduct we are still having growing
pains with body-worn cameras Baltimore
Police Commissioner Kevin Davis says it
is too early to tell whether body camera
video taken at this traffic stop last
November shows officers planting
evidence
what do you stop with force which may
step up what do you stop gonna stop the
public defender's office says the
officers initial search for drugs came
up empty then they turn their body
cameras off at least three different
officers begin recording again showing
the moment drugs were recovered from the
car their credibility right now is in
question because of a moment in time
that's either captured or not captured
on body one camera in another body cam
video from January a different officer
is seen allegedly planting evidence in a
backyard Davis issued a memo on Tuesday
reminding all officers to keep their
body cameras activated until leaving the
scene and warning that under no
circumstances should they attempt to
recreate the recovery of evidence while
it's ugly and while I'm disappointed
that officers and these two incidents
recently did not have their cameras on I
think it's irresponsible to jump to
the police officers are engaged in
criminal misconduct
since equipping officers with body
cameras in May 2016 Davis says Baltimore
police have recorded a hundred and
twenty-one thousand hours for more than
seven million minutes of footage the
department's body-worn camera unit made
up of eight sworn employees and interns
is tasked with screening the video daily
Davis says that's not enough I know
that's a question from time to time by
folks why can't she review each and
every moment of body one camera footage
that's that's that's virtually
impossible I would have to hire hundreds
of people to do that law enforcement
sources say privately some commanders
view these cases as embarrassing and
disturbing and there is concern that
some officers on the streets of
Baltimore are taking illegal shortcuts
Charlie check the gays in Baltimore Jeff
thanks